- [Voiceover] Let g of x, let g of x equal
x squared minus five.
If f of g of x is equal to the square root
of x squared plus four,
which of the following describes f of x?
All right, this is interesting.
So, one way I could think
about doing this is,
well let's just try
each of these f of xes.
If this is, if this was f of x,
then f of g of x is going to be equal to,
well, everywhere you see an x,
you would replace with g of x.
So, it would be equal to
the square root of g of x,
g of x plus one, and g of
x is x squared minus five.
So it would be the square
root of x squared minus five.
That's g of x, that's g
of x right over there,
plus one, plus one.
And this would be the square
root of x squared minus four,
x squared minus four.
Well, that's not what they have here.
They have x squared plus four.
So this isn't going to be right.
We could try this one.
f of, I'll do this in green just for fun.
f of g of x is going to be equal to,
it's going to be the square root of,
well everywhere you see an
x, replace it with a g of x.
The square root of g of x plus one,
square root of g of x plus one,
well, that's gonna be
equal to the square root,
g of x is x squared minus one.
So, g of x is x squared, oh
wait, let me be careful here.
This is going to be g of x plus nine,
g of x plus nine,
g of x plus nine, very important detail.
We have a nine here, it's
gonna be a nine here.
And this is going to be
equal to the square root
of g of x, is x squared minus
five, x square minus five.
And then you're gonna add nine.
You're gonna add nine.
Well, what does that give us?
This gives us the square root
of x squared minus five plus nine.
That's gonna be plus four.
Which is exactly what
you have right over here.
So, if f of x is equal to the
square root of x plus nine,
then f of g of x is going to be this.
So, that's our choice, right over there.